e aí a gente vai enganar tudo com vocês
ainda lembra de mim em risco de apostar
dinheiro semana que a semana está muito
muito muito concorrida pra mim mas agora
tô aqui eu quero dizer a vocês que
amanhã também tem vídeo e depois da
manhã também teve de depor amanhã também
tem vídeo é ter um vídeo por dia durante
quatro dias porque o que eu passei um
dia sem posta aí vocês merecem vitorino
vai ser vídeo não é servido um bom
porque eu sou bonança vídeo bonita não
sei se vocês sabem além de fazer vídeos
no youtube e também faço comédia stand
up hã hã o que está na comida aquele
show de humor que fica pessoa de cara
limpa mesmo com o microfone na mão e vai
falar sobre como era a vida dela
trazendo um pouco as pessoas que estão
assistindo já faz algum tempo que a
galera assim assim eu comecei a fazer
vídeos youtube eu comecei com um som é
legal ser conhecido é legal você é uma
pessoa famosa linha legal assim você tem
fãs é legal fazer tudo isso mas antes de
tudo isso eu tinha o sonho de ser um
grande humorista e tem um nome como
humorista sabe lotar a casa de show em
todo lugar que eu vou lutar até o nome é
se um dia chegasse em um tom cavalcante
um tiririca 11 danilo gentili rafinha
barriga galera não não não é fácil de
jeito nenhum
teve um cara que está presente no stand
up em cima de um palco está com
microfone na mão e mesmo que você não
via de nenhuma nenhuma das piadas dele
tenho certeza que ele merece paulo
galera tem coragem para animar aquela
galera que tá ali tentar fazer aquela
galera e tentar fazer aquela galera fica
alegre gente não faz a pessoa quando a
partir do momento que ela pega no
microfone que ela sobe no palco a fazer
aquilo era uma pessoa vencer pra mim é
uma pessoa vencedora não é fácil mostrar
que as pessoas não te trata como uma
pessoa normal o bom de você ser
humorista é porque você é a pessoa da
galera você tá ali a pessoa está no
grupo ali a pessoa também junto com as
pessoas lhe você a pessoa engraçada do
grupo caso você falte automática triste
que não tem você pra contar piada porque
você é a pessoa até agora ruim é que
ninguém mais ninguém te levar certo do
que tu fala ela acha que é brincadeira
lucas lira lucas livre lucas é é não
sabe aconteceu eu bati meu carro
acho que abri a minha perna em 3 lugar
espero corresponder o brasileiro
os brothers foi tocar humano
cala a boca e aí começou a ser limpa k
ta vendo ninguém mas ninguém acredita no
que eu falo todo mundo leva na
brincadeira
a taxa é forma que o resto da situação
da tua vida quando a pessoa é comediante
ela pode fazer qualquer coisa qualquer
jeito vai bmf amp após beber veneno no
total sendo apontada no meu coração aqui
o negócio fica pior velho do douro pior
de todas pra mim é a seguir e faz o que
é bom faz um stand up eu sou humorista é
essa piada entanto 81 porque o neymar
que após a chegada tão motoristas ou por
conta piada é engraçado que o carro faz
exame de próstata ninguém chega com ele
faço então faz o que eu faço de próprio
punho do meu co e isso aí ninguém faz eu
faço um molde aqui no youtube aqui no
youtube eu fico sempre portar dessa
câmera sem tratar da terra de vocês eu
nunca estou aí com você e no meu show de
stand up é isso que eu acho é isso acho
melhor é poder ter essa interação com
vocês e vocês nem verde bege eu ver você
de perto eu saber quem é a galera que
que gostei o que vocês pensam quando
você está assistindo a galera que
comenta a galera que escreve tá ali ela
ia escutar amizade de vocês é isso
escracho [ __ ] pra mim coisa vou mostrar
pra vocês eu fiz um agora um show em são
luís meu deus do céu foi em
eu amei
o dinheiro
lá foi muito lindo claro olha olha o
tanto de presente não abaixo trazendo a
vingança aqui
adorei campeão a jéssica chamou de um
inativo não tem fim coxa é isso aí é
isso mas eu amo isso aqui de maio
retrato mas eu amo isso
com essa carinha de quem é e espero que
tenha gostado da minha cidade que
envolve muitas vezes meu nome é nulo e
eu tenho 16 anos conheceu no final do
ano passado o primeiro vídeo que assisti
foi um maravilhoso dia que eu fiz o enem
muito obrigado por ser um dos remédios
que alivia a minha dor você é um homem
de deus na minha vida te amo não demora
para votar em são luís já estou com
saudades beijo no seu coração com muito
amor e carinho de todo meu coração
sentimentos bons por você é da ludmila
morais brigada do dinheiro pelo carinho
e pela carta que não consegui ver nem
metade disso aqui só com certeza está
porque sabe que não conseguirem a
verdade se ainda porque ainda hoje eu
estou tentando ver todas as cartas e
todos por exemplo escolher aracaju
caracazo foi lindo demais então quer
dizer que uma coisa pra vocês todos
vocês de vós meus shows todos vocês que
que saem das suas casas ou no teatro e
assistir todos vocês que fazem isso
vocês estão contribuindo para a criação
de um grande humorista de verdade eu
quero muito eu quero muito que todos
vocês estão assistindo agora que eu
possa ir à cidade de cada um de vocês e
eu sei que tem muita gente que fala
assim a minha cidade é pequena a minha
cidade não tem tanto fãs eu não sei se
vai vir não importa eu quero em todos os
lugares que eu vou ficar muito feliz se
cada um de vocês tiverem cada um desse
show e quem quiser me dar presente eu
gosto de boné e um está só não só de
exame
eu amo demais aqui ó placar
eu tiro palestras cartão de ônibus de
palestras casa de madrugada gente eu
adoro muito isso eu quero muito que cada
um de vocês assista o que eu tenho de
melhor para mostrar a você a aproveitar
aqui para dizer que sexta agora dia 26
agora hoje e quarta-feira de do vídeo
seja agora dia 26 e eu vou estar em
brasília distrito federal a cinco e meia
da tarde no teatro unip e eu quero muito
que todos os bichos outro de brasília
esteja um presente pra fazer parte dessa
história porque eu não sei quando é que
o voto em brasília que vai demorar mas
eu quero muito que cada um de vocês de
brasília compareça neste a sexta feira
agora dia 26 às cinco e meia da tarde no
teatro unipraias e distrito federal
quero todo mundo lá onde é que tem
ingresso pra comprar o influenciou já
que tem ingresso à brasília gente
ingresso pro show de brasília na casa do
caubói taguatinga norte na casa do
ingresso na target da agá tinga na casa
do ingresso taguatinga norte também fica
do lado da casa acabou e você quer
estudar pra você que a estudante está 40
reais a meia entrada vou tirar foto com
todo mundo essa desgraça em wiltz conta
quem o its quanto é que o ingresso
intenso onde é que eu compro ingresso
índice que ora vai começar o indicador
que vai terminar o inter a gente vai
tirar foto e sempre vai fazer isso vai
fazer aqui todas as informações sobre o
show estão aqui na descrição do vídeo
todas no dia 2 de outubro tem aonde uma
marca que em teresina aqui na minha casa
terezinha onde é no theatro 4 de
setembro no dia 2 de outubro tinha 4 de
setembro e 2 de outubro passado mas ela
não tinha até 4 de setembro no dia 2 de
outubro às sete horas da noite tem
ingresso lá na hora tem ingressos a
marca informática no shopping é do lado
da loja americana no show que não é só
meu é de um monte de amigos vai ter
vários rumores você apreciar que
terezinha estou convidando você pára aí
essa gente eu quero que vocês façam
parte dessa dessa parada que é dessa
loucura que é fazer isso e em mossoró
dia 18
aí foi velho lá em mossoró está vendendo
ingressos na loja surfline no shopping
park center que não tem de mostrar ó lá
meu deus sabe o que é isso aqui foi uma
lata de coca ó
a galera está aqui foi um presente da
coca cola ea cemitério junto com esse
convite aqui que eu vou levar vocês
agora o windows uma coca-cola idealizou
o coca cola festival para o jovem
antenado no modo em que tem a opinião ea
atitude é exatamente o perfil do
trabalho que você tem realizado está
falando que vocês são os jovens e que eu
sou o melhor de tudo é exata é e então
nada mais justo que você participar
dessa festa entre a sua galera
o seu público que já gosta muito de você
acompanha por isso a gente já conta com
sua presença no coca-cola festival e
tenho certeza que você vai se divertir
muito além de ser muito bem a sediada em
haia 16 horas o que não é nada mal esse
kit é uma prova que gostamos muito do
seu trabalho contamos com você no dia 4
de outubro no shopping recife em spa e
pai é esta data na sua agenda a coca
cola já reservou um lugar mais que
especial pra você no coca-cola festival
abraços time da coca cola galera do dia
4 de outubro também votará em recife no
festival da coca cola e tem o site aqui
em baixo pra você e garantiu seu
ingresso vai ter bonde da stronda anp
nine fly vai grande recife
a eu lembrei de uma coisa que ir a show
em vez de uma coisa que eu preciso
contar a você eu to participando de um
concurso para eleger o melhor humorista
jovem eleita participa é um cara vai me
chamar para eu participar em outra
categoria dizendo que eu não conseguiria
ganhar e eu não conseguiria ganhar de
jeito nenhum sem o apoio desse cara eu
não vou dizer o que eu acho que eu não
vou dizer quem é o cara mas ele disse
por a mais b que eu não vou conseguir
ganhar sem a ajuda de mar
ele não conhece você não se cala não
conhece você falta um mês para acabar
essa votação vocês podem votar quantas
vezes vocês quiserem é só vocês
digitarem o meu nome o endereço nunes
quem é o melhor humorista jovem winners
11 é o primeiro site aqui na descrição
do vídeo site prêmio jovem você entra
faz seu cadastro venceram e nem tivesse
31 face 30 no twitter uma coisa absurda
assim aí vai ter um monte de categoria
você votar um no programa meio ao cantou
meu espanhol
6 6 mil novecentos e aquilo e tem quem é
o melhor humorista jovem escreve meu
nome certinho o inglês sondava o hss
tudo certinho nisso eles fundos se pode
votar quantas vezes vocês quiserem
quantas vezes quiser porque o e ficar
não sabe o poder que vocês tenham não
poder que eu tenho o poder que vocês têm
volta quantas você quiser todo dia marca
o do dia embaixo desse link embaixo do
minc é do www.premiojovem.com.br tem uma
portaria que eu fiz no facebook quando
você votar você vai lá essa postagem
você vai comentar eu voltei cinco vezes
eu voltei sete vezes eu voltei 50 vezes
eu voltei 190 e 20 e só que três vezes
beleza beleza para ver quem a cara de
ficar eu só quero ver a cara de ficar
gente muito obrigado por você assiste se
viu até aqui desculpa desculpa por
outros artefatos de show faria de de dia
que vai ter show do dia e fechou a
coca-cola sf e 4 de outubro no shopping
e se desculpa por ter falado show em
brasília cinco e meia da tarde no teatro
lírico 26 dia 26 na sexta-feira e se
poder falar do show de dia 18 em mossoró
nós ea gente vai ter quatro vezes esta
semana o vídeo a mãe tem nada nada a ver
com isso nada vêem um show com nada
achou vi bem legal bem interessante e
depois o meu prometo que essa semana vai
ser os melhores vídeos você assistir a
vídeo vocês muito obrigado a ser civil e
até aqui se você quiser deixar aquele
joinha para poder fortalecer mais ainda
você tiver dado uma risadinha se tiver
gostado que você comente e eu também
quero que você comente a descrição do
vídeo qual cidade você quer que eu vá
qual cidade você quer que eu vá lá que
eu vou
muito obrigado valeu mesmo é nóis
ribeiro pp itep
ai que legal é esse negócio vai da coca
cola o que eu vou no dia 4 de outubro o
festival da copa em recife no shopping
recife